So I have this program called holding cell fourth program.
Its components is the future arm program.
And I was speaking to consider their lives deeply and to develop a vision and a
strategy.
And it's not easy to have someone who hasn't been encouraged that say,
my vision has been on practice.
Avid.
People say,
well,
I don't know what I should be doing.
It's like,
well,
you know,
some things you shouldn't be doing.
So that's a good start.
I do need them.
And it was practical planner.
If you don't know what to do,
you would start by stopping doing all the stupid things that you're doing that
you know are stupid.
And that's a good start if it starts to clear your vision,
right?
So if you,
if you don't know what to do,
but you do know that you're doing things that you're ashamed of,
something you regret,
you could start by just
eliminated in one by one and slowly to the best of your ability.
And then there's your,
so that journey of matter is starting to become disciplined.
The false of ethical rules on some set of ethical rules.
And with any luck,
it can follow a set of ethical rules long enough,
then you'll get disciplines enough.
So you'll start to have a clear vision and then you might be able to see the way
forward.
Or you might see a way more important for intended rather than merely what you
should avoid.
So that's a good initial practical issue.
It's well,
because everyone knows you know perfectly well that there are things you would
do even,
you know you shouldn't do,
but you don't.
Stall
started stopping
because of the natural part of this idea about putting your house in perfect
order before you criticize the world.
Because there's a question that's always open and that's,
suppose this is the question,
so to speak.
They'd gone placed in front of cake.
It's like,
well,
how do you know the world?
Would we interpret places you weren't sent to Richard thing?
Maybe it wouldn't be.
And I don't mean might say,
well that's pretty challenging,
I'm sure.
Would you say to people who has a parent who's dying of Alzheimer's disease,
for example,
like wasn't gonna hit their act together and he's going to fix that.
It's like it made it a hell of a lot better than it wouldn't be otherwise.
I can tell you that.
And that's something because it's bad enough to have someone who's dead and you
and your family without having an incredible amount of unnecessary pathology
gathering around that and make something that could be merely tragic into
something that's outlined.
Hell No.
It happens to people all the time.
And so even if it's not the perfect solution,
the best solution that you have,
and then the next part of that is when I suggested to people that they do the
future authoring program and they're,
they're leery about doing it.
I asked them to do it back because a bad plan is way better than no plan.
Because if you didn't come into town,
they didn't learn why you should that plan.
Exactly.
Not Hypothetically,
but exactly in the world.
And then in the news,
that information above her failure to retool a better clap.
And so the English like manufacture,
you're tracking the destination,
it's moving,
there's some kind of ideal and your vision is blurry.
You don't know where to look.
So you're going to go this way and then you can go that way.
We can go this way.
But if you keep doing that big,
the deviations from the right path agreed going to decrease his time and
eventually you'll be walking forward in an efficient manner.
And you might have to take all sorts of errors before you manage that.
But I've watched people long enough in my clinical practice to know that waiting
for Kudos and very bad idea and not going up as a very bad idea.
It's like implement the best plan and half a half
and learn from and that works and you get sharper at making your planets.
And then the other thing that we do with the future authoring program,
the school,
we ask people,
well,
maybe you can't decide what your passion or your calling should be,
but it's a pretty cool question.
But you like ask yourself some questions like,
well,
is there something you could do to improve your intimate relationship?
One thing,
is there a way that you can improve your friendships?
Is there something you could do at your job that would make it better than it is
now?
Even if it's something incremental,
could you do something more productive and meaningful with your time outside of
work?
Could you be slightly better at handling temptations that come your way?
Could you take care of herself somewhat better mentally and physically?
And you know the answer to all of those questions is jeopardy.
Yes.
And then you can even ask himself a simpler question,
which would be well into something that you could do that would make one post
things better.
Is there also something that you would have to,
and you can ask yourself that instead of telling yourself that you should,
which is the same thing,
might say,
well I would like my marriage and ask yourself,
well how can my marriage be better?
And you'll get a bunch of answers and most of you in place,
because if you really ask yourself the question like that,
the part of our agreements and magic and who's looking for new masters will tell
you.
And then we'll tell you a bunch of things you don't want to hear.
I load them with the things you already know and some of them will be thinks
that there's just no gam you,
even though you know that you should,
but some subset of those might be things that you should do that by your own
definition that you actually would
we,
is there a step in the right direction?
So eight would ever step in the right direction.
You're willing to take day by day and that's incremental progress and it'll
little spire awkward.
It does fire up well.
There's a stage of the New Testament,
which actually happens to be a true statement,
which is to those who have everything more will be given.
And it's a,
it's a reflection of underlying phenomenon that looks like phenomenon.
It looks like a natural law,
which means that as things start to recruit to you,
the rigging average,
they move further accrue will increase.
That's a natural law school.
Price's law sometimes or deport for Credo,
it's reflective and creative distribution.
So there's a chapter 12 rules for life called don't compare yourself.
Compare yourself to where you were yesterday,
not to someone else's today.
And it's an injunction for incremental improvement.
If you don't know where to go in your life,
well think about where you are and see if today could make,
where do you are somewhat better on some dimension so that when you go to bed at
night,
you're not as rich as you were when you woke up in the morning.
And so if you do that in the two years,
you know,
one thing a day,
just a small thing,
something you could actually do that you would do,
then your life will be way headed.
And at the end of that,
you might have enough clarity of mind to start to understand where you would go
if things worked out from across the world.